all right well while the knights are in
Florida their mascot chance is holding
down the fort right here in Las Vegas
gonna be at the watch party up at Circus
Stadium Swim tonight well we've got the
back story not only on chance but on
gila monsters are Lauren negretti at the
Nevada Department of Wildlife office in
the Southeast Valley hey Lauren
hey you guys yeah that's right chance
actually got his name because Vegas took
a chance on having hockey in the desert
we love a good word play around here but
as far as what a Hilo monster is to talk
more about it I'm joined by Nevada
Department of Wildlife here Doug Nielsen
so Doug what is a Gila monster a gila
monster is actually the only venomous
lizard found in the United States it's
native here and uh they're home right
here in Clark County definitely yeah
that's a something that a nod if it has
a Terrain and the uniqueness that the
vgk team wanted there as well so and
talking about uniqueness here no need
for Branding because they have some
individualityness to it talk about that
here they really do and if you look at
the the body on here you can see these
different bands of coloring that come
across and those bands are as individual
as your fingerprints so a biologist
who's been researching these can
actually identify a different specimen
just based on the banding pattern super
interesting so again take that photo of
those unique fans but stay away venomous
yes well thank you so much for being out
here with us and talking about gila
monsters appreciate it you're welcome
it's been fun it's been so much fun and
again chance will be there at Stadium
Swim tonight there so again here live
over here at Sunset and Pecos Laura
negretti 8 news now and go Knights go
you bet go Knights go very interesting
thanks so much Lauren that was cool